have an accent of some sort somewhere
comes from you know think in all these
boys laughing life's all funny she's
talking about the audience take me I saw
how about that that's you out ha hey
what is going on YouTube now recently
your subscriber asked David what do you
think about that cash me out ha how
about that girl you think it's cool that
he's getting popularity for the stuff
that she's doing now most likely for me
I don't really give two [ __ ] but I got
a do say that this guy didn't see the
fake ID ah ha ha no I was buzzed by
modeling around Instagram turns out this
girl has over seven [ __ ] million
Instagram followers get what's up I know
what you're thinking if this is a video
about not promoting this girl and
getting her fame for being a [ __ ]
dumbass
why would you make a video about it
because it's on my mind and I kind of
want to understand what the [ __ ] is
going on in this world I remember there
was a time when somebody who was stupid
disrespectful and [ __ ] illiterate
people would say that you dumb but for
some reason I guess that translates to
now I wanna be like huh and I kind of
heard all the reason I just want to see
the type of stupid [ __ ] she's up to
I don't like this [ __ ] [ __ ] but
she's kind of entertaining though so why
not let me tell you something you cannot
openly talk [ __ ] about somebody say that
they're gonna get nowhere in life when
you are supporting her [ __ ] lifestyle
that's making her a good jillionaire and
then I [ __ ] found this [ __ ] out 13
years old 13 [ __ ] kidding me
I want you to really think about this
out there people of the adult world that
are watching her and supporting her
content this thirteen year old is making
a [ __ ] more money kinda [ __ ]
money than us
it's so weird nowadays the type of
things that we [ __ ] support and and it
only goes under that excuse of well it's
just entertaining for me I think my main
problem with this has to do with the
fact that if we as viewers and consumers
kind of support this type of lifestyle
you guys already seen it on YouTube
people tend to imitate people who do
well on social media and by creating
this extra positive atmosphere for
negative things that she's doing and how
to show like young viewers or just
people in general that a [ __ ] you I
could be a piece of [ __ ] and it doesn't
really matter I'm just going to do that
and I know some of you guys are like why
the [ __ ] is you hurt you very Vince well
I just want to say this first of all
suck the tip of my dick [ __ ] number two
I'm just thinking about it in kind of
like the long-term sense
not so much in short term me Ashley is
having a fun and she's you know
everything's cool like that but at the
same time like is this the type of
behavior that we really want content
creators to really follow it I don't
think that's what I want it's wrong for
me to wonder if she would still be
acting like this and she got her [ __ ]
ass look I don't know understand if
she's hood as she claims to be I'm
pretty sure a [ __ ] swift kick right
to the puts would fix that attitude if
anything it might fix her speech
impediment - catch me on fire
how about you guys might have a
different opinion
I don't really [ __ ] know what s just
kind of like an ending thought I do want
to say this though for those people out
there that are writing comments on her
Instagram and saying this [ __ ] I'm down
fool she is [ __ ] 13 you dirty ass
[ __ ] [ __ ] pedophile
you are jacking off to a [ __ ] 13-year
old you should be able to stop it up
yourself talking about over she was my
age let me tell you something if you are
above the age of 18 and you're looking
at a 13 year old saying oh if she was my
age you are the starter kit for a rapist
is this science in fact no but I do not
want to be associated with an adult
who's like thirty [ __ ] years old
talking about he wants to bang a [ __ ]
13 you'll get your [ __ ] life together
with y'all [ __ ] pervert ass walking
by Elementary
go like you go into a buffet walking
into a baby gasps like your life tinder
you can put your only healthy snack
being baby carrot because it reminds you
a baby hey what's going on YouTube let's
talk about something real quick now my
videos have been a little bit not I was
diddled waddling over now that I was
terrified of dangling of